hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
I'm going to show you a simple
one-minute test that you can see if
you're at risk for a heart attack okay
it's an exercise test and simply you're
you're assessing your resting pulse rate
you can check it right here on this
pulse here or in your neck okay so a
normal resting pulse rate is 72 alright
so yours could be higher or lower but
you just want to check your resting
pulse right then what you want to do is
you want to do a high-intensity
full-body not a hundred percent of
capacity something like 70% or 80% of
your full capacity so it's like a a real
hardcore workout for one minute okay so
your pulse rate is going to go up let's
say it goes up to 130 okay or 120
whatever it could go up to 160 so you
want to record at the very end of that 1
minute workout you check your pulse rate
again okay record it so then what you're
going to do is you're going to wait one
minute and you're going to reassess
recovery pulse rate okay let's say this
went down to 120 alright so basically
what we do is we take the difference
from B to C we were subtracting the
piece pork or pulse rate peak pulse rate
from the recovery pulse rate after the
workout and we're going to give us a
number we're measuring how fast that
pulse rate comes down from exercise so
we spiked the pulse rate and then we see
how fast it comes down all right now if
it comes down less than 12 beats that's
like right here this is only 10 beats
right here it comes down less than 12
you're at risk for heart attack this is
a real valid way to detect your ability
for your body to recover from exercise
or in stress if your numbers are between
13 and 20 you have a moderate risk okay
not too bad you're right in the range
it's kind of the gray area but if you're
between 21 and 40 you're good that's
normal you know to worry about it
your heart is responding normally I have
patient
that are 50 to 60 they could come all
the way down they can get their pulse
right way up and come all the way down
within a minute they're in top shape
they're like athletes so if you can get
your heart rate to respond like that
that's amazing one of the best
indicators - for health and
cardiovascular function is that recovery
wave and I want to explain I have a
machine that measures us and what
explain what that means recovery
recovery is not passive it's active so
part of the nervous system that raises
your pulse rate is called the the
sympathetic nervous system it's a flight
or fight and part of its in your
adrenals part of its in other parts of
your body that basically adapts your
body distress so let's say you run up
the stairs your pulse rate goes up the
blood pressure goes up everything goes
up right as soon as you stop the the
opposite system kicks in called the
parasympathetic okay parasympathetic
that is a system that is an active push
down wave like thing that pushes the
pulse rate down so it calms you down
it's the thing that keeps you in a state
of relaxation it's the thing that keeps
you asleep at night so it's an active
recovery wave so it's this system is in
the background working hard to keep your
pulse rate and 72 it's in the background
working hard to chill you out but it's
inactivated like when you're under
stress so that's really what we're
measuring is the parasympathetic
strength of your heart and your ability
to kind of come back to a setpoint and
if that system is weak it's a good
indication of you're at risk for heart
problems so anyway how do you fix that
problem well you start doing exercise
mini workouts and then you give a lot of
rest in between you start working your
heart you get your pulse rate up and
then you just let your body recover
because very few people realize that
recovery is this parasympathetic and if
you can just do a little short little
spike and then let your body recover
it's kind of exercising to recover your
your heart so
it's all about resting in between the
exercise it's about resting in between
the sets of exercise backs went on
that's how you strengthen this of course
will sleep we'll do it going on long
walks will do it good nutrition will do
it but so many people are focused on the
exercise part they're not looking at the
recovery part which is even more
important than the actual exercise and
ability to spike your pulse rate and do
a hardcore workout so just I'm shifting
your attention to something in the
background that's very very vital so go
ahead and check your own recovery and
see how you're doing and then you can
improve it over time thanks for watching